[Music]
what's a fourth of july celebration
without fireworks
brilliant colors exploding in the air
the oohs and oz they elicit on the
ground
fireworks are so high-tech these days
it's easy to forget they're not a modern
invention
historians believe gunpowder the
explosive ingredient in fireworks
was invented in china around 1000 a.d
it's said that in a famous battle the
chinese emperor illuminated the sky with
it
scaring away the enemy
during the renaissance the europeans
invented the type of fireworks we know
today
modern pyrotechnicians use computers to
ignite fireworks from a safe distance
and to synchronize their births with
music
[Music]
assembling explosives into fireworks is
the job of the pyrotechnician
even the tiniest spark of static
electricity could set them off
so anti-static gloves are a must
a firework is made up of separate
compartments within a shell
the burning fuse explodes one
compartment at a time
creating those staggered bursts in the
sky
the pyrotechnician first glues the main
fuse into the bottom of the shell
the glue is naturally colorless it's
dyed blue so he can tell
exactly where he's applying it
he puts the bottom aside to work on the
second compartment of this two
compartment firework
he starts by spooning a powdered
explosive into the center
then he caps it here he's working on two
fireworks at a time
next step a brown cardboard shock
absorber
to shield this compartment from the
first compartment explosion
then a corrugated cardboard disc and a
plastic spacer
it'll take the fuse one and a half
seconds to burn through these two
components
creating a slight delay between the
first explosion and the second
gluing the second compartment together
is tricky
if it's too tight it'll stifle the
explosion but it has to be tight enough
to withstand the delay with the second
compartment done
it's time to prepare the first he glues
a sleeve onto a case
then fills it with hundreds of stars
stars are what create the flashes of
color
they're carefully measured explosives
mixed with coloring agents
such as magnesium for white copper salts
for blue
and charcoal for orange the
pyrotechnician must handle them gingerly
or they could detonate
next he adds comets another type of
exploding decoration
[Music]
he tops it off with gunpowder
[Music]
finally he glues the two compartments
together
filling the remaining space with the
same combination of ingredients
once the shell is full he glues on the
cover
and the tighter the better the more
pressure that builds up
the bigger and more spectacular the
explosion
[Music]
next he wraps the fireworks in kraft
paper
the label uses international color codes
to indicate the size of the shell
the lift charge a gunpowder bag with a
long fast action fuse
goes at the base of the shell that's
what will send the firework into the sky
when they light the main fuse at the top
it simultaneously lights two secondary
fuses
the time delay fuse inside the shell
running through the compartments of
explosives
and that long fuse running along the
outside down to the lift charge at the
base
once the lift charge ignites heat and
gas build up inside the launch tube
until they explode
propelling the firework close to 1 000
feet
skyward
let the light show begin